[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Mike Florio joining us now the
investigation over Tua re-entering
Sunday's game becomes more important
with what happened last night uh what do
we know about Sunday Mike and then we
can get to last night well and Dan we
were tracking all of this in real time
on Sunday as it was happening when Tua
came back into the game to start the
third quarter a lot of people were
surprised because we saw what happened
after his head hit the turf in the game
against the bills he got up he was
wobbly a teammate had to actually
intervene and hold him up now here's the
issue and the NFL was very gracious they
responded to my initial email they sent
me the concussion protocol they answered
some basic questions
but when you look at the concussion
protocol there's a major question that
remains to this moment unanswered and
here's how it goes you mentioned the
fencing fencing posture when a player
demonstrates the fencing posture as Mike
Ryan explained it they are immediately
out for the game it's a no-go they can't
come back under any circumstances but
for gross motor instability the
wobbliness that we saw on Sunday there's
a loophole
the team physician and the independent
although not really independent of the
league independent of the team they call
it the unaffiliated neurotrauma
consultant those two individuals working
together can clear the player if they
determine that the gross motor
instability was not neurologically
caused so that's what they did and I've
been trying to drill down on that hey
NFL
why did they conclude that what we saw
and you know it when you see it we saw
it and we know it he was wobbly from
hitting his head on the ground what did
these two individuals do to come to the
conclusion that the gross motor
instability we all saw wasn't caused by
a brain injury that's it because that's
the only way he gets back on the field
and I think that's why the nflpa
launched the investigation that's the
question that I can't get answered and
needs to be answered because Dan
he should have been
not return to the game and then after
the game
does he get cleared to play by Thursday
night if he's in the concussion Protocol
no I don't know I don't know but he
never should have been back in that game
so something I just posted a little
while ago they need to close that
loophole now if you have gross motor
instability just like the fencing
posture you're done there's no way back
onto the field that game that's
something they need to do right now
going into the games this weekend
because we may be right back in this
situation with another quarterback or
any other player come Sunday afternoon
or Sunday evening if I gave you one
question to anybody in this
what would be the question and who would
you ask it to well see I practiced law
so I know how to take one question and
turn it into 10. there are some parts
Stan to the question I actually just set
a list of nine questions to the NFL
about Tua from Sunday I'm also curious
was he examined again after the game on
Monday on Tuesday on Wednesday or was it
just hey he's good to go he's back in
the game we're not going to revisit this
at all but I'm curious about the
unaffiliated neurotrauma consultant
because they recognized back in 2009 or
so we can't just rely on the team doctor
to make a reliable decision because the
team doctor is under the financial thumb
of the team and we've heard about that
for years the doctors do what they have
to do to continue to be the team doctors
they'll eventually find a doctor that
gets their players back on the field but
Dan just because this other person isn't
affiliated with the team
they're still affiliated with the league
and is it really in the League's best
interests to have the best players not
available for the best games there's
still
a subtle bias there it's one step
removed from working for the team but
the league still wants the best players
out there the league wants maximum
interest maximum eyeballs maximum
dollars so I'm not so sure this
unaffiliated neurotrauma consultant is
truly independent and the question I
have are we at a point where there needs
to be someone who is truly disconnected
from the NFL they'll hate that they
won't want it they they want to control
everything but maybe we need somebody
who's truly independent who looks out
for the best interest of the players and
not the team or the broader League that
wants those players on the field
I mentioned this in the first hour then
I I hope my audience is patient with me
because I'm repeating some of this
[Music]
um
is it just a coincidence what happened
on Sunday and what happened last night
that there's no connection between the
two for two well there's two different
issues here as you said earlier when you
have one concussion you're more
susceptible to a second one
that's one thing as we talk about
long-term effects how many concussions
does a person have what does it do to
them from a cognitive standpoint when
they're 50 60 78 the other issue is far
more important and that is suffering a
second concussion a second head injury
in the immediate aftermath of suffering
the first one that's how people die
that's why high school kids every year
somewhere between 10 and 15 they die
because they had a head injury that was
undiagnosed and then they had a second
one and the damage to the brain can
become exponential with an impaired
brain that gets injured again that's the
real risk here and that was the first
thing that I was concerned about he had
a concussion Sunday maybe he definitely
has one now well if the one on Sunday
was a concussion and here's another one
he could have a very serious if not
fatal outcome and that's the thing the
NFL needs to be concerned about
especially the NFL tries to be
the Platinum standard for all the lower
levels of the sport to emulate and and
it really hasn't worked the way the NFL
would like but the last thing the NFL
can have is a serious outcome like that
where you have head injury guys somehow
back in the game and has a second head
injury and has a serious outcome so it's
not just the accumulation of concussions
it's what happens when you have a second
one not long after a first one but you
know what happens Mike we've been doing
this a long time
it's a Friday
we're going to go into college football
we're going to go Bridge any objects
yeah the NFL and Monday Night Football
and then all of a sudden the Dolphins
are off for 10 days
you know Patrick Mahomes does something
Incredible or uh Lamar Jackson you know
I mean you know how this works we move
on we move best time for the NFL to have
scandals is in season because there is
an endless supply of bright shiny
objects she got Thursday you got Sunday
you got Monday you got Thursday you got
Sunday you got Monday and we do we do
but this is something that hopefully
people will remain Vigilant about and I
think that that
it will be a big deal and it should be a
big deal because it defies Common Sense
what we saw Sunday defies common sense
and what we saw Thursday night horrify
us even though he's fine it still was
horrifying in the moment and I think
it's time to take a step back and
revisit the concussion protocol and say
is there a way to make it better is
there a way to make the players safer
and one of the questions I have Dan
is there a higher bar that needs to
apply to players who are playing on
Thursday night whatever the injury is
there a higher bar for clearing them
because you've only got three days to
recover from any injury you may have
experienced on Sunday concussion or
anything else can you protect yourself
on a football field can you successfully
get through that game without being
impaired by the injury you had on Sunday
when you're playing on a short week yet
we accept that Thursday Night Football
is here to stay and it is but that
doesn't mean there aren't ways to
improve how we protect the players who
are expected to play
four days after they just finished the
game thank you Mike good talking to you
Dan Mike Florio pro football talk pro
football talk live that precedes our
show on peacock Monday through Friday